どんなやすい
僕は初めてあるためにこんなことを聞いて
い
皆さんは
どんな妻が好きですぞ
僕は
今日をもってきた
こんな野菜たち
これら
カエルや生き物がたくさんいますので育っ
た野菜たち
女野菜たちは僕は好きなん
なぜなら僕は帰れが好きなん
今
会はたくさん入っていけるような方向で
農業に取り組んでいます
皆さん
カエルってどんな生き物が知っています
帰って行ってもいい考えてもらおう
水で陸地どちらの環境もなければきていき
ません
豊かな生態系があることの目安となる
そんな存在
何より
見た目がかわいい
僕はこんなカエルが好きで学生時代です
栃木山梨ながらといった場所で彼ら
追いかけていました
カエルがたくさんいる地域には素晴らしい
自然景観がありました
こんな風景の中で僕たちは
不安もありがとうございますと言っていた
そう思った
こうやって過ごしていたなんかていないん
普段暮らしの中から
カエルを守る帰ろうを大事にすれしっ
あまり持っていません
東京で普通に暮らしていたん
何も考えずに便利な世の中を生きています
その裏側で追って環境畑へ
生き物たちのカエルたちのインチは少し
ずつスキーで行けることを考えません
僕はカエル魔物って息巻いてたくて
これじゃ切って帰れば守れていない
大きい値段
働き始めて
僕の価値観を変えてくれる人たちとであり
ます
彼らは
どうやっていけるのか
同様な敵変わっていくのか
って本当のこととは何かを考えさせてくれ
ます
巡り巡ったところまで考えてい
帰ろう偽モノを守ろうと思ったら
クラスともも考えればいけないとその時に
感じたんです
さらにある人と一緒に暮らすことになって
僕の前世は
どんどん変わっていきます
その人は上手くなっては僕の人生の中でへ
とても大事な人にある
こんにちは山田由美子です
この人は今一緒に帰るをかけている仲間
ですん
遠くから
学生当時なら
して対応ってきます中稀
それが今でもその台湾で一緒になって
海を守る活動していん
それはカエルや
もう自然を大事にするスペースを変える
スタイルという活動です
感じたい
僕たちがクラッシュ始めたのはう
奄美大島ん
帰れの楽園です
そこで島の生き物を守る
そんな仕事に就いたんです
ここで暮らさず3 day
僕たちどんどん変わっていっても
普通に買って食べるんじゃなくて
山や海で捕って食べるっていう
おからではできないことができですよね
ちゃんと帰りとかあとはからねとかね
いっぱい撮ってきたよ
それから
この時から僕たちの磯作り始まったねうん
味噌だが作って
ようにするしてたら
同じ ak 遊びに来てねー
なんだこれねえええ
そんな奄美で暮らして4年
僕たちがもっともっと一番を大事にして
いる暮らしをしたいと思っ
ノンカイにあることにします
今あれ水といっ地域農業してい
その食べずには
これと言って特に
宮文
感じなかったねー
その脈が前
魅力があっけないというところが僕たちに
とっては
ちゃんっ
ぞ魅力的にをもらう
誰も面白いことやってないところね
家から面白い形レベルというのだ
逆でそんなことを考えながら私たちは
たるみせずに移住しました
今べきたちの活動はしだてなっているのは
その
no 4
特に私たちの脳じゃ変わってるからねその
a
私たちは耕してない産後にもんからね
探せないので
ワールで穴をあけてそこに一本一本な絵を
説明します
これが本当にきつい
田んぼ一番晴らすのに
僕は1週間を旅している
隣のたのは2時間くらいで終わっちゃうの
で
日高私たち何してんだろうって思ってある
よねうーんでもねぇ
そんな大変が作業なんだけど
周りにはカエルがたくさんイン
絵画拡散いてくれるおかげで僕たちは
そんなきつい対応作業も楽しくなっちゃう
んです
特に雨の日のた a は最高
な悪いか不信になってて
カエルの声自分の生き抜きたい
ちょっと太っ家られる音の世界
それでー
言わせたい
ちゃったようなそんな感覚になりしてい
ません
まして
帰れなくてもの
2分
ああああああああああ
そんなことを検索てくれるこの田んぼには
イマームスや鳥
草や蛇なるをたくさん生き物が集まって
くるそんな単語に変わってきています
子供達もこの田んぼが大好きだよね
でこれも家の柵ちゃうからこれこれ
おーん
分かりません
1で醤油決まってる
家では毎年秋になると醤油を仕込んで3
年間かき混ぜて自分たちに醤油を作っ
他にも味噌とか工事とかオス何度ん自分
たちに作ってよ
銀河醤油や味噌の形を書いてくれる
これもおかえりたいだね
まあ
ああああああ
第ようにこのあった調味よって
僕たちはじゃあ自分宅に作っちゃう
それが許容性始まれ
私すっごい料理苦手なんですけど自分で
作ったチャム匂いでご飯作ると
料理塾に思われる拉致なんです
さっきより先
自分たちに作ってるって言えば
こんなの
自分たちで作って
これは小屋を返している
はしているところです
で次に家を食べてその中にオナラと台所
作りました
私たち休める今レーンはお風呂都内で国際
賞を勝ったねそうだねー
毎日あるとばクチネリ託したり絡んだり
くっ
外でお湯を沸かして移動グラン生活が続い
た月は9きちゃったねうんかなりん
あああん
保存たちは1個至る育ってねはーい
姉ができて
なにょですあったかッうん
蛇口ひねれば水が the bell
そんな当たり前のことが
涙が出るほど嬉しかったよね
あとお風呂ができて最初にいう音一
カッター
いませんか
それまでの家づくりのプロガー
全部ぶっ飛んだ瞬間だったよねうん
今は風呂が大事な機会になってるね
家ができて普通に生活できるんだったら
周り友達が全くいないということを言って
たんでねねぇ
あのしばらくいう水
引きこもってこんな事ばっかやってたから
ねぇ
それで始めたのがあ私たちのプロシアして
もらう体験してもらうワークショップでし
た
家では味噌
そういう
そういうのをみんなで作るワークショップ
をしてい
こう言って控える主体を広める等
同じもできちゃう
まさに一石二鳥の取り組みです
他にも
種が当館回展開を切られたり
千葉変わったようなリズム点を打ちのな
いって言われたり
相内隊の活動はどんどん広がっていきまし
たん
こんなは帰りたいの活動って
に生まれてくれます
車の色中とか
子供達が寝た後とかねえに伝え話
次に何やりたい何やりたいですか
あるが面白いとか考えてるから
ちょっと変わったフェットね
面白いことに分野部は風です
でも
そういう2人の考えの中で
ディスタイルの新しい間にどんどん生まれ
てくる
最近では
地下があ
シンナーはどうするかってね
常4月で色々やってたらどうしますか音楽
いやー
5体の活動
それを少しは皆さんに star さん
うん
わたしたちが楽しく暮らしながら
生き物やパエリヤを守って
いくっさいそれが私たちですからねそうだ
ね
引っ越してきた最初は周りからすごい変な
目で見られています
でも最近では市中津ばに興味を持って
くれる人がすごく増えて期間
にせず帰るスタイルがもありません飼い
始めてるって実感できるね
スマ
イヤー分かりますありがとうございました
ん
下越され
ません
たちの毎日こうやってやりたいことだけ
やって
会津前に楽しく
でも
しないことも
沢山の
例えば
こういう活動ってなかなかお金につながら
なくなりつながらなかったり
でも
僕たちはこうやって帰る付帯していること
は
生きている実感につながっ
子供にも願って
父ちゃんこんなことやってんだって言える
ようなきたかです
もし今日
ちょっといっ
行ってみたいな
店をつくってみたいなぁ
そのように感じた方は
帰る際は後
あなたは書いた瞬間幹線
何かやりたいけどどうしたらいいんだろう
そんな人は
家で始めたんでしょ
作ってみるのもいいかもしれません
他にも
よかったら家に遊びに行ってみてください
カエルスタイルの発動に触れることで
何かやりたいことを少しでも見つかるかも
しれません
全然降っ改定
生まれて死んだらそれで終わり
すべては僕はやるだけじゃないかと思い
ます
皆さんが
名する世界体
どんなでします
僕が考える世界は
僕とつながっている1
ce
田んぼや畑あ
そこでの暮らしへ
そんな世界の
くださいん
僕はこれからもやっていきます
あなたも
あなたなりのカエル伝える
探してみませんか
海もあるし定期的に姿形を変えてそれまで
となく違う世界に行きます
僕たちは
と買われる
僕はそう思います